un bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 60,18 l'édition pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
ce mercredi 3 février jusqu'au 6 février
c'est la semaine olympique et
paralympique un évènement pour
promouvoir le sport chez les jeunes à
cette occasion saint quentin en yvelines
organise des animations autour des sites
olympiques point d'orgue aujourd'hui
avec la venue de tony estanguet au
vélodrome nationale on en parle avec
laurent mazaury vice président aux
sports et l'apparat triathlète élan
courtois cécile sabouraud rencontre ce
soir avec mary look est 5e joueur
mondial de parade à edmonton il prépare
actuellement les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo 2021 pour ce faire le sportif
bénéficient des infrastructures et du
soutien de la ville d'andrésy enfin elle
est en cours de construction à la
verrière la nouvelle crèche ouvrira ses
portes en septembre prochain dans la
commune yvelinoise 45 berceau au total
dont 22 supplémentaires pour la
structure située sur le terrain de
l'ancienne protection maternelle et
infantile et qu'une engagements de
plusieurs maires pour sauver le sport
dans les quartiers populaires c'est à
suivre également dans ce journal
jusqu'à samedi c'est donc la cinquième
semaine olympique et paralympique
impulsée par paris 2024 le rendez vous a
pour objectif de mobiliser la communauté
éducative autour du sport promouvoir
aussi à la pratique chez les jeunes
c'est dans ce cadre qui est venu
aujourd'hui à poissy roxana maracineanu
la ministre déléguée chargée des sports
était ce matin la cité scolaire le
corbusier en compagnie notamment de la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
au programme rencontre avec la caravane
santé de l'urss qui tentent de
démocratiser la pratique santé du sport
et puis échanges avec des athlètes
élèves et le président de la fédération
française de triathlon au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en
revanche c'est tony estanguet qui
étaient présents le président du comité
d'organisation des jeux de paris 2024
est venu à la rencontre des jeunes dans
le cadre de cette semaine olympique sur
place bixente mayence anti steban et
michael et demi d'euros l'ancien
champion de canoë tony estanguet s'est
mis au cyclisme le temps d'un après midi
le président du comité d'organisation
des paris 2024 était ce mercredi 3
février au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son objectif promouvoir le site retenu
pour les jo de londres le cadre de la
semaine olympique
on est ravi de pouvoir partager ce
moment avec la génération de 1024 c'est
tellement important au delà des
compétitions d'engager d'entraîner avec
nous cette génération de leur donner
envie de découvrir ce sport leur donner
envie de découvrir aussi des athlètes et
moi je remercie toutes celles et ceux
qui ont permis cette opération cette
semaine olympique et paralympique à
l'école parce que cette semaine on va
mobiliser 500 mille enfants qui un peu
partout sur le territoire vont être
mieux sensibilisés à l'importance de la
pratique sportive
cette semaine olympique a été lancé à
l'initiative de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports
cet après midi une centaine de lycéens
de saint quentin en yvelines a pu tester
le vtt et le bmx avec le triple médaillé
d'or aux jo ça fait plaisir de voir sur
quoi les futurs athlètes ils vont
travailler et c'est franchement ça fait
plaisir de boire 1
un athlète de niveau
ça m'a donné envie de voir les jo et
voir le bmx géo il faut quand même rossi
tuer ça dans un contexte historique les
jeux en france et une fois tous les 100
ans si on regarde derrière nous et que
l'on puisse associer le plus possible la
jeunesse à l'engouement que cela va
provoquer autour du sport
c'est à mon avis ce qu'il faut
absolument pas manquer dans la proche du
de ces jeux olympiques de 2024 la
semaine olympique se terminera ce
vendredi sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines avec la découverte
de la colline d'elancourt le site
recevra les épreuves de vtt en 2024
mais la semaine olympique et
paralympique on en parle à présent avec
nos invités en plateau laurent mazaury
bonsoir bonsoir vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué aux
sports merad vend également de la
commune d'hallencourt et j'ajoute que
vous êtes le président également de t&d
78 avec nous en visioconférence cécile
sabouraud bonsoir alors vous êtes parra
triathlète de la ville d'elancourt
membre de l'équipe de france et vous
avez pour objectif de participer aux
jeux paralympiques de tokyo cette année
on va en parler dans un instant déjà un
petit tour de parole avec avec les
invités pour parler de cette semaine le
fait de parler de sport d'olympisme aux
jeunes est ce que c'est important est de
faire profiter justement de ces jeux aux
jeunes générations
normal c'est très important à plus d'un
titre le premier titre c'est parce que
ce seront peut-être les athlètes de 2024
un certain nombre de ces enfants qui
sont pratiquement des préadolescents
aujourd'hui seront peut-être les
athlètes de demain donc c'était très
important et c'est très implanté un clic
et deuxième titre ce peut être également
nos bénévoles parce que nous avons
besoin de bénévoles pour parler de 1024
et où aller les chercher système dans
les territoires où vont avoir les les
différentes épreuves donc c'était
fondamental
et puis un troisième titre c'est
l'exemple au mental exhibe à redon
l'exemplarité du sport pardon la fête
qui l'humidité aussi de l'extérieur
l'exemplarité du sport et montrer ses
athlètes entre autres tony estanguet qui
était cet après midi au pied de nombreux
pour être ambassadeur
le président et en plus quel athlète
médaillé à plusieurs reprises mais des
d'or aux jeux olympiques et on a besoin
si on veut pratiquer du sport d'avoir
des emblèmes alors des exemples à suivre
mais des exemples qui vont au delà du
sport des exemples dans la vie de tous
les jours des exemples dépassement
d'exemple dans le respect des règles
également le sport c'est tout ça
l'exemple dans l'égalité tout le monde
est égal face à une ligne de départ tout
ça c'est important de montrer nos
enfants cécile sabouraud louis de parler
des jeux olympiques des jeux
paralympiques dès aujourd'hui les jeux
auront lieu en 2024 à paris c'est
important aussi pour les jeunes
générations
à votre avis oui oui c'est très
important et c'est effectivement pour
voir le sport donner envie aux jeunes de
faire du sport est aussi il va
particulièrement concernant c'est une
semaine qui a déjà démarré à saint
quentin en yvelines avec des activités
ludiques qui ont été proposées aux
jeunes au golf national aussi on va en
venir on va y venir dans un instant
cette semaine c'est l'un des objectifs
affichés aussi laurent mazaury c'est
pour promouvoir les bienfaits de la
pratique du sport
la pratique santé finalement c'est ça
c'est l'acide a montré que ça doit
commencer dès plus jeune âge que le
sport c'est tout ce que j'ai dit avant
mais c'est aussi se maintenir en forme
et par les temps qui courent je dirais
que c'est très important se maintenir en
forme
montrer que c'est un élément que la
mobilité le déplacement le mouvement est
un élément pour se maintenir en forme
et puis également que ça participe à une
forme de sérénité de l'esprit qui permet
d'affronter les épreuves du quotidien
donc effectivement ce qui s'est passé au
golf national lundi
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui au
vélodrome nationale et ce qui se passera
on en parlera peut-être un instant
vendredi à les collines d'elancourt va
dans ce sens là c'est à dire les plus
jeunes leur montrer l'engagement du
sport et leur montrer également toute la
partie santé que le sport génère et en
ayant également la capacité de faire en
fonction de ce niveau en fonction de ses
appétences en fonction de ses envies
certains vont préférer le goff d'ondres
préféré pourquoi pas la natation
ailleurs et s'est montré toute cette
panoplie que le sport ait montré tous
les bienfaits qu'il peut apporter
cécile sabouraud j'aimerais vous
entendre également sur cet aspect la
vocation santé du sport peut-être aussi
que d'une certaine manière on peut
guérir grâce au sport je précise un peu
votre parcours en 2004 vous avez perdu
votre jambe droite dans un accident de
la route vous étiez auparavant cavale
or plusieurs titres en championnat de
france championnat d'europe également et
malgré cet accident et après une phase
de reconstruction vous êtes remonté en
selle et vous avez brillé à nouveau et
depuis quelques années vous vous êtes
tourné vers le paratriathlon qui mêle on
le rappelle la natation le vélo et la
course à pied
en quoi le sport vous a aidé dans cette
épreuve de la vie est-ce que ça a été
une forme de thérapie pour vous ah oui
oui moi si mon mac bien avait
effectivement déjà partie avant mon
accident et j'ai pris vraiment besoin et
psychologiquement et physiquement j'ai
eu un petit creux à un moment quand j'ai
raté liquidation j'ai arrêté le sport il
je précise d'ailleurs que vous avez à ce
jour deux titres de championne de france
de paratriathlon en 2019 et 2020 est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous donné comme mission
aussi de témoigner sur le sujet
peut-être auprès des jeunes générations
justement oui oui 13 ans vit
effectivement à dérider les fleurs
génération à se lancer dans le sport pas
forcément mais aussi juste dans la
pratique leur donner de l'espoir avoir
envie et comprendre qu'effectivement le
sport apporte beaucoup vraiment beaucoup
de choses surtout pour les personnes qui
ont besoin de se retrouver devoir faire
des courses de paluzza est dans une case
voilà ça permet de recouper énormément
de choses et voilà et 307 communiqué
croix est d'ailleurs aussi parmi les
objectifs de cette semaine olympique et
paralympique c'est celle de faire
changer les regards sur le handicap est
aussi de faire découvrir aux jeunes les
disciplines paralympiques son nom
revient à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
laurent mazaury on imagine aussi que
l'objectif d'un tel événement c'est de
faire grimper tout doucement
l'engouement jusqu'à jusqu'à paris 2024
a bien évidemment ça s'inscrit dans la
droite ligne de la préparation des jeux
olympiques et de l'engouement pour la
population je rappelle que le premier
objectif que l'on se fixe alors parlé de
1024 attendu il ya toutes les valeurs de
l'olympisme dont j'ai parlé mais c'est
surtout à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'appliquer la population a démontré que
sont les jeux olympiques certes du monde
entier plus d'un milliard de
téléspectateurs
mais c'est avant tout les jeux
olympiques des saint quentinois est
effectivement impliqué les enfants de
nos écoles s'est impliqué derrière les
familles s'est impliqué le tissu bien
entendu éducative s'est impliqué aussi
les entreprises
enfin voila c'est vraiment un noyau
complet qui doit autour de paris 2024
être présent être moteur il participait
être actif le regarder porter la parole
de 2024 et montrer qu' il y aura un
héritage appareils 2024 j'ai eu
l'occasion de parler ici
ces avancées pendant les jeux et ça sera
après et après ce sera tout bénéfique on
en aura t'il le bénéfice qu'on n'en a
attiré en matière sociale et en matière
éduquer de l'éducation mais c'est
également les équipements qui resteront
la colline de l'encours est un exemple
équipement qui sera ouvert au public et
donc montré aujourd'hui comment on peut
déjà d'utiliser deux c'est déjà être
certain de demain elle le sera et pour
le plus grand nombre
nancy une semaine olympique et
paralympique qui justement fait le tour
des sites olympiques de saint quentin en
yvelines elle a débuté depuis lundi et
ce mardi est des enfants étaient reçus
au golf national localisé à guyancourt
au programme activités ludiques autour
de la discipline et découverte du site
théâtre on le rappelle de la ryder cup
en 2018 le sujet de bixente n'a rien
senti stevan sur la voix de nicolas
landry dans le cadre de la semaine
olympique et paralympique le creps ile
de france organisée cette semaine des
activités pour les classes de primaire
ce mardi 2 février c'était découverte du
golf au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines première
activité qu'on a fait et 20 heures
on devait tir d
avec les balles ces voix là est la
deuxième on apprend des petits secrets
pour
dans le tronc que c'est la confiance à
des jeux du golfe et même si j'arrive
quand sens très bien je conseille
cependant en plus des différents jeux
ludiques une visite du 18 trous qui a
accueilli la ryder cup 2018 et sites
olympiques de paris 2024 les jeunes sur
le fort de demain on a maintenant voilà
les champs jusqu'aux jeux olympiques
pour pour préparer pour les sensibiliser
pour leur montrer que voilà sur la sur
la commune de saint quentin en yvelines
voilà il ya magnifique outil sur lequel
ils pourront enfin j'espère un jour voir
demain pratiquer le golf donc c'était
très bien au lieu de les accueillir
comme parrain de cette semaine olympique
et paralympique le jeune à carreaux
avaler 16 ans connu pour son combat pour
l'insertion professionnelle des
diabétiques
il intervient auprès des jeunes pour les
sensibiliser sur la thématique du sport
santé à chaque classe j'essaie de les
sensibiliser par rapport à cette maladie
donc moi même je suis diabétique de type
1 depuis quatre ans maintenant et donc
je les sensibilise par rapport à cette
maladie à la gestion cette maladie au
niveau du sport et aux bienfaits du
sport pour les personnes diabétiques
mais aussi non diabétiques parce que ça
permet à rennes devrait vrai équilibre
au niveau du fonctionnement du corps au
total ce sont plusieurs centaines
d'élèves répartis tout au long de la
semaine pour cette découverte sur le
green du golf national l'a découvert
donc des différents sites olympiques
présents à saint quentin en yvelines ya
le golf national on était tout à l'heure
au vélodrome nationale ça va se
poursuivre vendredi laurent mazaury avec
cette fois ci une animation proposée à
la colline d'elancourt tout à fait des
animations pour les scolaires à la
colline d'elancourt qui partira du bas
de la colline et bien entendu montrable
savez que c'est le point de claude
ile-de-france donc une perspective
extraordinaire et puis c'est le seul
point pour le coup qui sera en devenir
puisque donc certains colline existe
mais elle n'est pas aménagé aujourd'hui
donc c'est important je pense de montrer
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui de montrer ce
qu'elle sera demain donc on leur
révélera un petit peu des secrets ils
auront la primeur de son d'informations
qu'on l'a même pas encore des vrais la
population n'y a pas de grands secrets
se doute parler de la piste mais c'est
également de parler beaucoup sur la
partie économique et les jeunes sont
passionnants sensible et c'est là aussi
en les sensibilisant aujourd'hui qu'on
aura demain des citoyens qui sont
respectueux de l'environnement
montre à tous ces travaux qui auront
lieu pour ouvrir cette colline au grand
public et le sport est avant tout à
paris 2024 je leur précise bien sur la
colline d'elancourt qui accueillera les
épreuves de vtt sur ces jo 2024
ajustements avant ces jo de paris
il ya ceux de tokyo cette année les jo
sont du 23 juillet au 8 août les jeux
paralympiques du 24 août au 5 septembre
cécile sabouraud vous vous êtes lancé
comme objectif de participer
justement à ces jeux depuis 2018 vous
êtes miso paratriathlon vous avez été
championne de france déjà à deux
reprises en 2019 et 2020 et vous êtes
aujourd'hui membre de l'équipe de france
où en êtes-vous dans votre projet
olympique est ce que il ya toujours dans
un coin de votre tête de participer à
ces géo cet été ah oui combien est de
toute façon
aux dernières nouvelles les jeux auront
lieu sous vide oui et ils auront lieu
donc effectivement le président du
comité d'organisation des jeux de tokyo
à dire que les segio se tiendrait quoi
qu'il arrive vous en êtes vous en êtes
encore loin de ce projet de ce rêve
olympique
pas tant que ça effectivement j'ai
débuté le paratriathlon il ya deux ans
et demi je suis de deux ans moins deux
fois je n'étais donc une saison avec les
problèmes sanitaires qu'on a eu cette
année je n'ai fait qu'une saison entre
et argent donc j'ai peu d'expérience
dans le classement et j'ai fait peu de
compétition du monde cette année m'a
permis de m'entraîner et le député dans
la pratique c'est la progression est là
il j'aimerais cet avis quand même
j'espère qu'on pourra participer à
quelques compétitions pour voir les
progrès est en effet un peu amélioré
pour être au top à tokyo
est-ce que vous avez aussi dans un coin
de votre tête les jeux de paris
justement à huy les jeunes arrivent
alors avant paris on le disait il ya les
jeux de tokyo à qui elles doivent se
tenir c'est
été malgré les risques d'annulation les
athlètes se préparent pour les fiancés
il ya il ya eu donc cette prise de
parole du président du comité
d'organisation qui a dit qu'a priori ces
jeux pourront bien se tenir
parmi les athlètes de qui participeront
à ces jeux olympiques et paralympiques
il ya mairie loket qui est joueur de
parra badminton quintuple champion de
france et numéro cinq mondial son
portrait signé par bixente maria
scientiste et ban c'était un
entraînement plus en détente que
d'habitude pour merrill loket
le jeune balle liste de 23 ans a appris
récemment qu'il devrait participer aux
prochains jeux paralympiques à tokyo
c'est l'aboutissement de d'un
entraînement c'est à ces quatre en
préparation c'est du stress est long et
puis c'est le graal quoi c'est le graal
des compétitions et puis on représente
son pays à l'international c'est moi y'a
pas mieux plus jeunes le désormais
quintuple champion de france ne s'était
pas destiné au badminton
il a longtemps pratiqué le judo avec
pour idole un certain teddy riner qui me
disait là les sports de combat n'y a pas
plus dur comme entraînements et j'ai
découvert les entraînements de bad et je
suis sorti épuisé
et là j ai pas ce que je fais du sport
pour le support le surpassement
pour sa préparation merrill bénéficie du
soutien de la ville d'andrésy en plus de
la mise à disposition d'infrastructures
pour l'entraînement elle lui a accordé
une bourse exceptionnelle avec en plus
le retard de ces jeux d'une année
on avoue vraiment donné un gros coup de
pouce pour sa préparation pour pas
qu'ils soient démoralisé toute aide est
bon à prendre
et quand servir d'une d'une ville de la
oumma on a vécu toute notre vie ça fait
encore plus plaisir
objectif médaille à tokyo pour l'actuel
5e mondial et dans un petit coin de sa
tête plane le rêve de remporter les jeux
paralympiques de paris en 2024
justement cécile sabre ou comment ça se
prépare ses jeux paralympiques vous
disiez tout à l'heure des stages avec
l'équipe de france et aussi des
compétitions qui qui se déroule en ce
moment oui loïc tous les deux mois
l'équipe de france les réunit pour faire
des stages d'environ 10 jours voient
l'avenir quelles conditions le stade de
france c'est vraiment très dynamique et
motivée voie ils mettent en condition
régulièrement par exemple dans un
dernier stage que j'ai fait ce mois de
novembre du parti allaient libérer à
l'île de la réunion pour se mettre en
condition climatique
et voilà un crédit pour leurs bijoux
intensément sous la chaleur on a vérifié
un peu comment résister à la chaleur
pour notre corps réagissait en mettant
un agent d par exemple des puces pour
savoir si une fois rentré fort en
température sur les températures de 35
degrés voilà savoir si on avait aussi on
était bien m'hydrater et savoir comment
notre corps allait réagir à ces
conditions climatiques puisqu'elles sont
diminués avec la chaleur et l'humidité
voilà pour la forme est 7e cette page
olympique laurent mazuray on revient à
cette semaine olympique et paralympique
je leur précise elle se termine ce
samedi
on le disait tout à l'heure faire
grimper tout doucement à l'engouement en
vue de ces jeux de paris 2024 du coup
une semaine olympique qui sort sera re
re re proposer pardon jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'événement passé durant tout à fait
c'est à ce sont des pointillés jusqu'à
l'événement et c'est comme ça qu'on fera
monter la la pression et la tension
et puis comme je suis sur le plateau je
vous délivrer un scoop il est très
probable qu'ils aient même à 9,9
de golf cette année voyez comme quoi
tout arrive et que le changement de
président mais participe à une sélection
et je rappelle que le golf est également
une des cités dont un pic c'est donc
important d'avoir tous ces petits
éléments plutôt très important
d'ailleurs qui viennent se positionner
jusqu'à ce que 2024 soit chez nous et
que les jeux olympiques de paris donne
avec 24 soit jeu rapide de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 2024 également
merci alors mazaury d'avoir été avec
nous au vice président aux sports de
saint quentin en yvelines et merci
également à cécile savoureux d'avoir été
avec nous je remercie d'ailleurs est
avec nous et bonne chance dans votre
rêve olympique on suivra bien sur ce
parcours dans nos prochaines éditions
utiliser le sport justement comme outil
est d'éducation et d'inclusion l'objet
du premier grenelle sur le sujet qui se
déroulait en début de semaine à garges
les gonesse dans le val d'oise à
l'origine cinq maires qui faisait partie
de ces élus à avoir lancé l'appel du 14
novembre pour demander de consacrer 1 %
du plan de relance aux quartiers
prioritaires parmi ces édiles il faut
pour ces édiles pardon il faut sauver la
pratique du sport dans les quartiers
populaires parmi eux justement catherine
arnould maire de chanteloup les vignes
que je vous propose d'écouter par
exemple à chanteloup ça fait plus de dix
ans faut pas loin de 15 ans que pour
nous le sport et la prévention 100
tonnes sont intimement liés parce que le
sport c'est avant même d'être la culture
du plus beau plus fort plus grand c'est
d'abord une espèce de culture en commun
qui fait que c'est l'endroit où on peut
rencontrer nos ânes c'est l'endroit où
ils passent ensemble des temps de petits
bonheurs et c'est aussi l'endroit où on
peut le mieux les connaître
donc le sport c'est exactement la vie de
la ville parce que c'est la vie de la
jeunesse et lors de cette journée les
maires ont formulé douze propositions
pour sauver le sport dans ces quartiers
notamment la construction est de plus
d'un millier d'équipements sportifs la
mise en place de dix mille contrats
types et d orienter vers les
associations sportives ou encore la mise
en place d'un fonds d'urgence pour
soutenir les associations socio
sportives dans l'actualité également la
montée des eaux sous surveillance dans
les yvelines
le département placés sous alerte orange
ce week-end après de fortes
précipitations est repassé depuis en
vigilance jaune à la crue pas d'urgence
donc même si le niveau de la seine est
montée s'est tenu par endroits de 10 cm
la situation des prochaines
précipitations est suivi de près par la
préfecture des yvelines
plusieurs communes ont d'ores et déjà
activé leur plan communal de sauvegarde
à poissy que vous voyez à l'image des
habitants ont reçu des flyers leur
expliquant la marche à suivre en cas
d'inondation et des pompes ont été
activés également sur l'île d'er mignot
à poissy direction la verrière pour
refermer ce journal pour faire le point
sur le chantier de la nouvelle crèche
dans la commune pas de retard malgré la
crise sanitaire l'ouverture de ce nouvel
équipement est prévue pour septembre
prochain et les précisions dans ce sujet
d'eléonore sinoquet de patrick jacques
de dixmude 22 berceau supplémentaire
c'est l'objectif de la nouvelle crèche
de la verrière en cours de construction
un projet à 2 5 millions d'euros
financés par la ville en grande partie
mais aussi par la caisse d'allocations
familiales des yvelines et le
département on augmente quand même notre
nombre de berceaux à 22,2 pour passer à
45 berceau au total aussi pour regrouper
les différentes structures de la ville
dans un unique emplacement pour être
plus performant dans l'accueil des
enfants et des familles c'était une
vraie demande une vraie impatience même
des familles avec des horaires qui
seront au maximum adaptés aux horaires
de travail des parents on pourrait que
le plus facilitateur possible
ce nouvel équipement regroupera les deux
microcrèches ainsi que la crèche
familiale située sur le terrain de
l'ancienne protection maternelle et
infantile
la nouvelle crèche fera 700 m² au total
et une volonté de travailler sur
vraiment
environnementale puisque on est parti
pour acquérir la certification hqe eux
donc haute qualité environnementale et
pour ça on a travaillé sur toute
l'isolation du bâtiment sur les énergies
renouvelables pour toute la partie
le chauffage est très demandeur donc on
a aujourd'hui un équipement qui est
vraiment moderne et intégrée dans ce
sens mais l'environnement ouverture pour
la prochaine rentrée en septembre 2021
les inscriptions ne sont pas encore
ouvertes mais la municipalité la sur les
45 berceau seront attribués dans les
plus brefs délais c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité dans un
instant nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
la thématique ce soit va-t-on assez loin
dans la lutte contre la maltraitance
animale les députés viennent d'ailleurs
d'adopter en première lecture le projet
de loi sur le sujet c'est à suivre sur
tv 60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]